That's absolutely gipping.
Hello everyone.
Hello.
Don't say hello to me, Dan,
say hello to our loving
audience, they're right there.
Hiya!
Hiya.
You all right?
Cinnamon challenge!
I've never done the cinnamon challenge.
I've never done it, seen it done.
Obviously the entire internet has seen
the entire internet coughing
and choking on cinnamon.
Yeah.
So let me, where's your spoon?
Pocketed, nice.
Bit of cinnamon.
How bad could this be?
I don't know.
People like, dying here.
If I chunk...
If you chunk, we'll
film it in slow motion.
Oh, cheers.
Okay, all in, and try and swallow it.
Are we ready?
Yeah.
Oh, God.
That is not good.
Oh, .
I'm glad you're finding this funny.
So how do you feel about all the people
that done the cinnamon challenge?
I think they didn't do it again.
You know what though, it's over.
You have to do it now.
I don't want to.
You're doing it.
I still feel like AIDS.
Yeah?
Yeah.
I reckon you were being a big baby,
and I'll just be able
to swallow it just fine.
Yeah?
No.
Down the hatch.
Now try and swallow it.
Ugh!
Can't stop my leg.
That was bad.
Yeah?
That wasn't great.
Was that as bad
as you thought it was gonna be, or not?
I feel like all the fluid in my head
is trying to evacuate.
I might throw up.
I puked a little bit.
Well, thanks for watching that video.
What have you got on your face there?
Lunch.
Be sure to follow us on Twitter.
That was the worst in the world.
Watch the next video.
I'm never doing that again.
Oh, man alive.
That was a mistake.